yeah when we first met we were like
Neighbors on the Upper East Side and um
that's right drink at that dive bar like
Mug Shots we I was like yeah you me
Sharon the Upper East Side crew I was
like violently poor like me and Sharad
used to call our apartment squalor
because it was just so unexpected we had
a shower in the kitchen those were such
fun days though I remember uh we had a
lot of fun we were so poor but I was
having so much fun I I that was I was
sleeping on the uh the futon and mine
was actually a studio apartment that
they slammed a wall into yeah we called
it a one bedroom and I was like I have a
one bedroom apartment no to me you were
rich I was like I know a successful
person and then I met the chick upstairs
who had the exact same unit above me and
his words are just like this giant
Studio
and uh I I never even brought it up
to my landlord or anything I was just I
I knew oh that they sold it as a as a as
a one bedroom I could have complained
and gone to the board and done all of
that but I was just like dude I really
want to waste it's like all right I've
never gone to anybody who has time for a
board yeah I did it one time really yeah
against the taxi driver what happened
what was the situation
um we got into it on the uh the FDR
trying to [__] who was gonna go and I
ended up
winning who was going to go next you
know those New York battles with the car
yeah so he was [__] I could see him
yelling at me and [__] and I was being
you know I was being a dick so I was
just sort of like are you doing it he's
peeping the horn and everything and I
was just waving and I think and then
when he drove by me he took like he had
a handful of chains this point we
finally got on the FBR we're doing like
50 and it was raining out yeah and he
[__] took his hand full of change and
he just was [__] throwing it at the
side of my car he did it like three
times he had just changed this is the
night like the 2000s have changed
this was just throwing it it was like
can you change on this side and I'm like
you [__] [__] he did it again
and he was such a dick and I was so mad
I was like all right [__] this guy and I
got his number and I actually complained
and then we showed up
it was so funny because we showed up for
the hearing and by then I wasn't even
mad anymore and he showed up with a
lawyer I remember when he's this Asian
guy and he tried to make it racist
really well first of all he admitted
that he threw the change at me yeah and
so I was like why the [__] would he do
that why would he admit first of all he
had a lawyer it was him his lawyer and
me sitting talking to this guy in a desk
that was like half the size of this in
this little room
and we would just saying there's nothing
Dumber the two men mediating after they
had a stupid [__] it was really bad
it was really I ended up feeling really
bad so
he admitted that he threw the change at
my car but he said he goes uh he goes I
did it because I look over and he he
would he was looking at me he was going
like this what he said I don't know why
he even said Charlie calls you a hack
and I was just like so I was just like
you're telling me I was driving 50 miles
an hour in the rain and I took my hands
off doing that and then that's when the
lawyer jumped in he goes I literally
have here there's a couple people that
got a little upset
and the guy he ended up getting
suspended for like a week there is then
I felt bad I just wanted him to I don't
know why it's one of the few vindictive
things I've ever done and I felt bad and
this is the [__] funny thing is I
[__] got a cab like a month later and
I swear to God I think it was him and I
got in the cab and I saw the picture and
I heard his voice I don't [__] know
right and so I just sat directly behind
him and I was just sitting there like
that I was I tipped him well in case it
was him
all right there you go I've had that
happen before getting back in a cab
where I've had like a weird moment it
probably was him I had that one time
because it was this crazy white dude who
his claim to fame was he auditioned for
like Metallica or something and he was
one of those guys he had like Surfer
energy that was going on the whole story
they do that here that's why I can't
take the Ubers here they just tell you
the whole yeah their band everything
um they play things for me somebody
plays something for me on the way over
he was like playing me his tracks and
stuff I'm like you're networking with me
I don't want to blame the victim here
but how does the conversation get that
deep don't you just put some headphones
on sorry I have to take a call no this
happens actually with to me all the time
that's very fair yeah people just tell
me things and then they'll start like
weeping and stuff they're like I've
never told anyone this before but I
definitely something's happening with me
that I've pulled because that would not
happen with Billy like you would nobody
would start to no people do not open up
to me no I've like gently held people I
don't know very well